[Music]  Miley Cyrus and Liam Hemsworth hiking  with their pups in Los Angeles on  Thursday unless the luckiest ever he is  all the exclusive pics of the pair's  adorable outing with two of their dogs  Mary Jane and Dora the Explorer how many  dogs would you have now is this you  they're all they're all rescues but  there's there's a few in the house check  out the dues um and their fitness gear  approaching the end of their height  we're so excited  Miley is clearly in tip-top shape her  abs are on full display in a red sport  bra a matching short shorts and sneakers  liam rockiness shaggy urdu with his  white key and gym shorts each with a dog  on a leash each rockin stylish shade and  before heading out to pair with snaps  packing up their Range Rover together  everyone's waiting everyone's everyone's  over  you  [Music]